loyal readers it's been 349 days since I
said yes to the love of my life
Richard Bevan Carlton Kane evaldo via
some hell through all this insanity I'm
still me even though I'm about to become
queen of a small country I can't get
over the fact this is gonna be my home
until the wedding you're going to have
your own bridal suite Sweden Wow I can't
believe this is actually happening it's
real it's very very real Christmas
spirit has overtaken the palace and I
have the world's best wedding planner
see he designs he does not believe we
have much preparation to do and very
little time I can't see we are looking
for you darling perfect I'm looking for
something more contemporary Aldo BIA has
traditions life in a fishbowl takes
getting used to
we're gonna do a brilliant job you're
having some royal pains
it's like bridezilla in Reverse
don't write it's just not working now
that you're part of the royal family we
must be careful of the image you project
I just always thought that my wedding
would be about being with the person I
love I didn't realize the about having
to give up Who I am
I suggest that you cease from any
activity pertaining to your blog
immediately no way your majesty the
titles and responsibilities we bear can
overwhelm any person especially a
good-hearted one
your wedding is about you and Richard
everything else is secondary I'm so
sorry
[Music]
you
you